you
welcome everyone I prepared the present
day okay I didn't prepare the
presentation actually I made a game
because it's more fun to talk about
games while you play game right and we
had a whole bunch of really hardcore
technical talks yesterday and today
morning so just like treat it like a
break for your brain or something like
that and there is one issue I made a
game on the oh yeah console and I just
receive it yesterday okay two days ago
so it's not really stable so please be
patient just in case something will
happen and yep so let's try nice loading
bar hey so um let me okay i have my Chi
Chi somewhere I'm sorry cuz I don't
remember the special codes I need to
type in this game okay so let me
introduce myself first my name is mijo
buchinsky I'm a JavaScript developer
from Poland in Central Europe I
currently live in Paris and i work for
Mozilla and firefox OS team you know
what Firefox OS is anyone okay like
three persons yeah nice so that's the
new operating system made by Mozilla and
it's kind of web-based we have a great
booth with our community members in the
cafeteria they have some devices so just
if you'll have some free time or you're
just curious on what's how it looks like
just go there and try uh yeah yeah so
Moser is a microsoft if one of the
sponsors today so i will just leave this
site
by the way Thank You Microsoft guys for
the winter caps like I heard that
tomorrow it will be around 22 so it will
be really useful so I also organized
those conferences on games start this
html5 gaming event depth first one in
the world and so far the biggest one we
had three editions in Poland one edition
in New York earlier this year blah blah
blah I'm game started calm and I work
also on this project called Antarctic
Jas and it's maybe it's hard to like get
this from the name but that's the
JavaScript conference and Antarctica and
I've been there last year check the
venue and you have followed Antarctic
Jays and twitter for more info I hope it
will take place next year around
Antarctic summer and i'm also addicted
to TV shows i watch [ __ ] tons of crappy
TV shows all the time I have my github
repository of a list so so far since
tuta since 2010 I watched more than
4,000 episodes and that's more than
2,000 hours and if you if you go there
and see that there is one show that you
know and it's good and I don't have it
on the list just fork the repo and send
me pull request please I'm not kidding
really ok so as I said I didn't make a
game I made I me didn't make any stuff
okay you haven't seen that sorry mm-hmm
okay that wasn't really as I said that's
not really stable thing ok so here we
are again so the game is more or less
about
it's Thomas somewhere here can I switch
to my computer because I don't think it
want to cooperate today ok so so oh one
more thing even if I'm a game developer
I'm not really good player so I second
gaming and like playing and talking in
the same time it's impossible for me so
i will probably yeah i improved this but
I improved the wrists bound algorithm
recently so it should work better ok so
the game is like I just traveled through
the oh it's actually just slightly
changed site of on game start 2012 and
you control this astronaut inside the
spaceship with lasers and talk to people
this yellowish things are kind of people
ok so i will talk today about game
consoles and browsers and games so first
time i get interest in like I get an
idea that maybe it's possible to okay
that the idea of running HTML or any
even JavaScript on the game console it's
kind of new thing we I mean we have
javascript in like almost everywhere
like in the server side mobile phones
fridge printers whatever right so why
not on the game console and the first
attempt to do that I ever seen was
running JavaScript games on xbox so xbox
house has this thing called XNA so you
can basically run your own game britain
in.net and XNA framework on xbox 3060
and there is this small thing called
Jurassic and it's Wow no no no yes there
is this thing called Jurassic and that's
a JavaScript engine for.net so there is
this guy that made an impact jas game
engine Dominic's a black ski and he made
the first attempt to run his own game on
xbox so basically what he did was okay
yeah what he did was cross compiling
JavaScript to the.net bytecode and then
ran it on XNA and he has outstanding
performance of six seconds per frame so
that's not actually what we want to
achieve in games and okay okay yeah so
but as you could see for 30 seconds it's
possible to run JavaScript game on the
oh yeah console so oh yeah is this small
cheap not cheap inexpensive device that
run Android so you can run your android
games on this game console and there is
this cross compiler record kun je yes
it's made by the some startup from Spain
I mean they're now starter from Silicon
Valley it's always happens with European
startups after a while and they so it's
really easy I mean everything you need
oh I don't have it but so you need to
believe me that everything you need to
do is just write your game like you do
for the browser compress it to one zip
file uploaded to cocoon Jes cloud server
service and then download the APK file
for Android and it kind of works as you
could see I have no idea why it worked
for 30 seconds I I really
it worked in my room on my TV anyway so
that was a quite like new thing that but
why actually we want to do that like how
far is our console from our mobile phone
like what's the difference today I mean
okay the difference is obvious right you
know one has do you don't like work with
your PlayStation in your backpack like
most of the time and you don't play it
in subway but from the hardware point of
view like ps2 was 53 times worse device
than ZT open the cheapest Firefox OS
phone now so when when I when I saw this
thing I thought okay so why mobile
phones are not our game consoles now
right simple idea so oh I forgot one
slide because we talked about how to run
our JavaScript things on the console and
what about running console games in the
browser so oh this a lot of thing
doesn't work today but it so there is a
how many of you ever heard of Emscripten
okay so Emscripten is lv v m2 JavaScript
compiler so you can compile your C code
or Python code or whatever code to
JavaScript and run it in the browser and
we have this subset of JavaScript called
a sm j s so it's it's low level
javascript with memory management and
things like that so recently we created
this demo of the Unreal Engine in HTML
in
javascript is rendered using WebGL and
it was written in C so as far as i know
and it's kind of yes so you can work
look around and all this [ __ ] take in a
real game blah blah blah okay nice so so
what's the other important difference
between the browser and the mobile phone
so for me like the game changer is the
support of all the web api so we do have
now most in firefox OS but well when
they will became part of the standard
will have them in all the mobile
browsers and not only mobile browsers or
also desktop browsers as well so what
exactly like okay give me a second if i
want to create a game for the conference
next time please punch me in the face
okay so we have using web AP is we have
the main advantage for me is that we
have different ways to manage to handle
the input player input so on your gaming
console you just have your ipad and
that's all like oh this ridiculous
connect thing if you are too lazy to do
jogging in real life you can run in the
front of your TV right but in the
browser we have like the unlimited
actually ways of handling input so
probably all of you know accelerometer
right like we can use accelerometer from
our mobile browsers so like user don't
need to use a keyboard mouse or touch
events to control your game it just tilt
the phone and that's all I mean it was a
big thing
when it was invented now it's not really
original but yeah let's that's the first
thing so what about geolocation so
geolocation is more or less the GPS API
in your browser and there is whole bunch
of games that use them like I don't know
that's one of the game in where you need
to run to the particular place faster
than your friends or tour force is quite
nice it's like a gangster game but in
real life it doesn't sound very good
it's in the real and fire oh you get the
idea so and also like one of my
favorites but I couldn't find it is
there was a hackathon in war so a couple
of years ago and one of the like 48
hours to build the html5 game and one of
the team builds a geolocation paint
application so you just run with your
phone and then you could see like your
drawing on the map was kind of fun okay
sorry because I have no idea where my
next slide is okay upper platform
Oh No XC know yeah oh wait okay
yay so we have the gamepad API as well
so you can control your game with
gamepad so that's boring that's not
really something you want to do on the
browser because we have consoles for
that but if you write html5 game for the
oh yeah console for example you can run
it in you can you need to implement the
gamepad ap either and the API actually
like it'sit's though if you want to
teach your kids how not to create the
architecture of an API just show them
the w3c documents about the gamepad API
because it's like the worst API ever we
don't have events there but you need to
pull on every frame to huge array of
buttons and check if the button is 0 or
1 that makes no sense at all yep so
which one is the next Oh tight I hate
this part just in case yeah okay so what
about getusermedia so there is this
thing in the browser called WebRTC and
part of WebRTC is get user so WebRTC was
created to create skype like
applications inside the browser's you
have peer to peer connection and part of
this API is the get user media it's
access to your video and audio of the
browser so how many of you seen my talk
from last year okay like five people
great so it will be fun so I create the
really simple example of how get user
media works so that's the video
part those are just the puzzles like you
just need to grab one and put grab one
and grab one and put in the proper place
if you don't know where to put it you
can cheat like okay my hand is in here
yeah yep hmmm
voila yeah so that's the simple example
of how video can I mean that's not
really useful example but you get the
idea right and so how we can that's the
hardest part of this level I hate it but
how we can okay it's nice that we can
access the the video but how we can
actually use it so my idea from last
year I had to talk about the face
recognition and I created simple example
of so first of all what happens in the
first step is just we draw the stream
from the camera on canvas and run the
face detection algorithm there and when
the face is detected we stop like yeah
that's the first step so the second one
was we have a texture of the 3d model
from the WebGL game and then when we
detect the face we put the face on the
texture in the place where the face
should be so in this yeah [ __ ] yeah so
now we have a texture with our own
character and the second day third step
of course is to put this face on the
real model and so the algorithm detects
where the eyes are and put them in the
glass into the glasses where the nose is
and mouth and things like that so we
have our own 3d model and we can use it
in games or whatever
so that was one of the use cases one of
the things where you can use the yeah so
but if we can find the face in the video
can we use our heads as game controllers
and I had an example last year and I
think it worked but this year I couldn't
make run I don't know why there is this
game hook called head punk oh yeah
that's this and I'm not yeah exactly it
doesn't really work but what happens
there is you play a punk game with your
head that's quite kind of stupid but
it's possible so why not and like the
project i started last year and I'm not
working on it anymore was quite
controversial so if we can detect our
own face on the video can we detect the
face of the animal and there is this
library called kitty door I showed it
last year that you just put the cat's
photo there and it starts looking for it
and voila so we created together with my
friend the prototype of a game that you
control of your cat but I mean it was
quite fun for us it wasn't as fun for
the cat because oh I will not say why
but anyway you need to trust yeah so
where's the next side there i mean the
the game wasn't really a playable there
is is it even a word anyway because the
algorithm is really slow so we need like
a second for a frame so
that's not really funny but getusermedia
it's not only the video as I said before
it's also and people usually forget
about it it's also about audio so you
can access your microphone as well not
only the camera and so is it possible to
write a game that you control with a
microphone I mean of course it is
everything is possible right but let's
try so first of all I need to whoa no no
no no
whoops sorry
okay so first of all I need to do a
little calibration so please be quiet
for a second okay ok and now on three
can you all shout like really loud one
two three okay so I stole one of the
open source games example of the impact
j/s engine and I wrote my own plugin
that that blocks the keyboard control
and the character is always running and
it jumps when you scream so let's try
okay enough you get the idea yeah so so
we have other web AP ice as well like FM
radio API battery API light sensor API
and can we do a game controlled by the
battery status actually we could we can
I it's not really smart thing but there
was the guy like almost a hundred years
ago called Greg Mallory and he was the
first guy that probably attempt the peak
of Mount Everest but he died when he was
getting back or going there so we don't
know but like three years before he get
there someone asked him man why do you
want to do that and he was like because
it's there so I like of course we don't
need to use those AP is for our games
but they're there why not and I actually
don't have a demo I I'm it's a pity but
in Firefox OS in Firefox ok so in
Firefox OS simulator when you plug and
unplug your charger or your USB cable on
the phone it triggers an event so it
easy to create a game like to change the
game I did with a microphone for the
battery status API so the character
starts when you plug or unplug your
phone I mean it's make no sense but why
not you cannot do that with your console
right and towards next oh my god there
yeah so there is this guy said that
yearly or something like that he's a CEO
of the company called Crytek that's like
the biggest gaming company in the world
or one of the biggest dick sorry they
create the big titles like far cry or or
something else and he said in the Indian
interview last year that the next
console generation will be the last and
it's mostly because we have we don't
have so many hardcore gamers now like
regular gamer for for now for this time
is a women in late thirties should I
stop already or okay and playing like
twice a day with her mobile phone and
another thing really important is that
we have how many seven billion people in
the world something around that and we
have 10 billion phones and only four
billion toothbrush brushes so mobile
phone like mobile industry is getting
bigger and bigger and the next
generation of the cons of the next
console generation will be just in our
pocket because why not like and for the
last thing I want to say it's thank you
that's what's all actually
you